er ist für diese youtube in die leute
was gedacht jetzt willkommen beim neuen
video ich habe mir gedacht ich muss hier
noch ich habe fraktion jetzt ist somit
kann man hier schlug machen hier läuft
so ich habe mir gedacht kommen jetzt
noch mal wieder auf chatroulette ich
habe das schon aufgenommen im sind paar
ganz coole gespräch mal wieder warum
bekommen deswegen wünsche geförderten
wieder wer sich über das dann doch noch
unklar und metzger hallo wie geht's
scheiße warum merken hat dann getroffen
und sketchen mehr grad hat ist es in
youtube er erachtet momenten auch dazu
ein auch bußgeld solche jetzt wenigstens
hast du mich gerade wie es gibt oder
sowas nicht ausgemacht na ja ich möchte
dass gerade jemand machen weil meine
augen ich gar nicht kannte ich kann
nicht vielleicht ein bisschen aufmuntern
ich bin auch youtuber ich hab noch
180000 ist das auch okay hallo ihr müsst
nicht nein wirklich alles mit möchte ich
eigentlich tun
doch mal sowieso internet deswegen total
ständig weil ich habe dir nicht nur spaß
nein ich bin allerdings sehr milde der
ich würde wieder abgefüllt das gilt in
meiner tasche reitverein picasso bild
und da sitzt du mit deinem handy und
sieht aus wie ein handy
nun sei es menschen nicht bestellt also
bereich mir schon ein bisschen klang
geschichte zu finden so ein bisschen wie
welche leute zu finden
ach so ja ich bin voll kilt eigentlich
bei dir ist voll die disco ich weiß
nicht aber ich mal raus er ich musste
keine ausnahme menschen hinein starten
du brauchst auch aufnahme ja ich mache
auch aufnahmen kummer machen wir doch
gemeinsam größer bist du diese youtube
in letztem hallo also ja ich wills
irgendwas wissen oder so oder hast du
noch irgendwann liegen keine ahnung was
sind also ich will mal 5 millionen
abonnenten haben und dadurch millionär
werden nicht zulassen dass waren nicht
komplett ernst im 2
weißt du mir geht es jetzt nicht darum
dass das dass mir das spaß macht oder so
das sagen zwar viele aber das bringe
komplett nicht so also will ich damit
jetzt nicht 10.000 euro monat machen
will ich auch nicht machen dann seien
damals auch nicht immer
ich kenne ich woher fahrt geht weiter
kürzt die ich kenne ich ja ich hab dich
sogar abonniert
scheiße nein warte warte warte fahrt
fragt frank volk fragt fackelträger
scheiße dies nicht
das ist gut kam da nicht so sicher ja
ich hab so viel dem [ __ ] jahrbuch zu
youtube videos weil das steht was und
wie viele autos hast und wie viele euros
1 20-22 aber schlecht ich auf mehr
und dann musst du drei tage
wie heißt du dicker ich hab das was man
irgendwas mit dem spark alter was ich so
direkt dass mein youporn kann habe ich
weiß ja für den abriss und wieder auch
der irgendwo in china
du bist der du bist auch die befugnis
nicht nur auf super king kompliment egal
ich würde mal sagen bei dem ist nicht so
hallo hallo wie geht's nach die geht gut
und dir aber du bist jetzt nicht so
einer der ja auch irgendwie mich
aufnehmen sollte ist das ja keine ahnung
ich höre die ganze zeit aufgenommen von
irgendwelchen leuten weil die denken vor
das müssen wir machen oder so unnötig
richtig viel spaß ist okay leute sagen
das war ich erst mal wenn es euch
gefallen habe ich ja immer schon gesagt
keine gelder nach oben da lassen
abonniert vergessen ist um nichts mehr
zu überlassen was ihr auf jeden fall
noch sagen muss am sonntag kommt mein
erster eigener song online kann man das
so sagen ja ziemlich viel arbeit drin
wirklich freuen wenn ihr das sonntag um
15 uhr in abdeckt beschreibt euch das
irgendwie hinter die öhrchen also sind
selbst einmal als angewendet hier oben
links geht es weiter mit meinem letzten
video das war dinge die du niemals zu
einer freundin sein soll das könnt ihr
auch gerne mal vorbeischauen ich wünsche
euch noch einen schönen mittwoch bis
sonntag